hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website column and today we're
going to be starting a two-part series
on common mating patterns and I wanted
to do this series because I know when I
was learning chess and I would go back
and study my games there were so many
missed opportunities I had because I was
not familiar with some of these common
mating patterns and so that's why I
wanted to start the series as we go
through make sure that as you start to
learn these different mating patterns
that you do anything you can to reach
one of these situations in a chess game
even if it takes sacrificing a queen a
queen and a rook whatever you have to do
to reach one of these make sure that you
do that because obviously it's checkmate
so that's the point of the game so we're
going to go ahead and get into it look
at some of the most common ones and then
we're going to look at some situations
in a game how you can use that so the
first one we're going to look at is
Anastasia's mate and it looks like this
basically if you look at its White's
move white can move Knight to e7 and
then the King can move it does not
matter where he moves he can move to h7
or h8 and we'll just go ahead and put
them on h8 and then we can bring our
rook to h5 and it's checkmate
so let's go ahead and take a look at an
example how we can use this in a real
game so let's go ahead and look at you
pull it up here let's go ahead and look
at this situation if you want to go
ahead and take a minute pause it if you
want to and try to figure out what
White's best move is and how he should
proceed again remember the mating
pattern that we're trying to arrive at
and do anything you can to get to that
so first thing we're going to do
hopefully you found it is Knight to e7
the black king is forced to come to h8
and from here we can sacrifice our queen
to h7 the only movie has you parka C is
to capture on h7 and then we can bring
our route to h5 mating the black king so
in this example we sacrificed our queen
but we checkmated the black king so as
you can tell we take it simplistically
and look at it how it operates and then
we go a little bit in depth and see how
it works in a real game so let's go and
take a look at the next example go ahead
and take a look at this example and this
is the back rank mate and this is the
most common mating patrin pattern that
you are going to see most chess players
are familiar with it but I wanted to
cover it because it is probably one of
the most often seen mating patterns that
you will see as you can see here the
black king is trapped on this back rank
on the 8th rank and Y can come in with
his rook the d8 and checkmate the king
there's nowhere for him to go so let's
take a look at this in a real-life
example and see how we can use this so
if you look at it here and it's White's
move what is white specks move and again
keep in mind do whatever it takes to
reach one of those situations so from
here White's best moves you can probably
tell take a myth pause if you need to
but it's Queen to d8 checking the black
King the black King cannot move because
you would still be being attacked by the
Queen daelin move the black has is
capturing the Queen on d8
and then we can bring our rook to d8
capture and it's checkmate via the back
rank mate so always keep this in mind
and the second thing you always want to
make sure is that you're looking for
this on your opponent's side as well if
he has a potential back rank mate
against you make sure that you do
whatever it takes even if it means
sacrificing some of your pieces to make
sure that he doesn't do this to you
because again if he does it it's
checkmate so you want to avoid this at
all cost so let's go and take a look at
the next one let's take a look at the
next example and that is the Blackburn
mate
as you can see here the black mermaid is
made possible from our bishop here
attacking the King this long diagonal
being controlled by our other bishop and
our knight defending this bishop and
there's a few things that always need to
be in place for this to work first thing
we the black King to be cancelled on the
King side the second thing we need the
rook that's casted on King side or I
guess it could be the other rook to be
on f8 if he's not there it's going to
have an escape route for the King to
move next you need to have your bishops
on the long diagonals bishops work
really well on the long diagonals and
this is no exception in the black permit
you want your diagonals controlling
these long diagonals a1 to h8 and B 1 to
h7 last thing you need you need the
knight on d5 he's going to protect
everything and make sure everything runs
smoothly as you can see this is
checkmate let's take a look at it in a
real-life example here
and from here take a minute Paul's tell
me what you think is the best move and
hopefully you came up with the nice
little sacrifice Queen takes h5 now
black does have a few options here his
worst option is going to take the Queen
sacrifice white can now bring his bishop
to h7 and that's going to be checkmate
black can do two moves to try to make
sure that it's not checkmate
first one he can do is f6 we can come
Queen takes g6 he can bring his queen to
g7 we can move our Queens to h7 check he
has to take with his queen he can't move
his King we can't recapture with our
bishop on h7 he is forced to move his
King we'll just put them on h8 we can
now capture this Knight on e6 attacking
this rook on f8 black has to worry about
a few things if he takes our bishop we
can take his rook on f8
if he ever gets this rook off this F
file we can bring our bishop to f6
so we have a lot of different fighting
opportunities this all came about
because we notice the Blackburn's mate
and we executed the very beginning with
what looked like a coin sacrifice but if
black took that coin he would lose so if
he doesn't know the mate and he takes it
we're going to win but if he doesn't
we're going to gain a lot of material so
this is another way that you can
notice a mating pattern and benefit from
it so the last example we're going to
look at in part one of our mating
pattern series is the Boden's mate she
can tell from here it's a very powerful
attack from the two bishops against your
opponent's king as you can see although
it doesn't look like the bishops are
doing much the y king has nowhere to go
in their checkmate
so let's take a look at a real-life
example of how this would work in a
chess game if you look at this example
and you didn't know anything about
Boden's mate you may think that White
has a better game he's up in material
he has good center control everything
looks good well white doesn't know that
we know that he's very susceptible to
the bonus made so it's blacks move where
should black move and hopefully you came
up with Queen takes c3 now let's look at
White's options he can't move his King
to c2 and he can't move his King to B 1
because of our bishop on f5 here his
only move is to take our Queen and like
I said a lot of times you may have to
sacrifice a queen and a rook or a knight
whatever it takes to come to one of
these places in the chess game do it
because from here we can bring our
bishop to a3 and it's checkmate
we have Boden's mate so if you look at
it before you may not even notice but
now that you've watched this video these
are just a few examples that you may see
throughout your chess game that you can
always look for even when things may be
looking down
as long as you know these different
mating opportunities you'll have a very
good chance of winning a lot of
different games that you may not have
won before thanks for checking out the
video hope you learn something if you
haven't already please subscribe to the
channel and also if you haven't checked
out the website or if you haven't
checked it out in a while please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi for